es ist halb eins ich hab noch nicht
gefrühstückt und ich habe das letzte mal
agenten gestern abend um wie mode 8 uhr
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu schulschluss
fasten experiment kann man ohne weiteres
drei tage lang ohne feste nahrung
auskommen und stellt sich nach diesen
drei tagen eine fasten sowie ein mensch
kann er angeblich über 30 tage ohne
nahrung auskommen zumindest habe ich das
selber noch darauf und im letzten video
wenn sie das noch nicht gesehen habt
dann schaut es euch an heute ist der
donnerstag vor ostern ich habe
beschlossen es lediglich zu machen ist
passiert bei den christen mit der
ostermesse sonst bei abend gebrochen so
werde ich das jetzt auch machen auch gar
nicht so leicht drei tage zu finden wo
ich nicht unbedingt meine die
höchstleistung brauche für die nächsten
tage habe ich mir vorgenommen die den
unternehmen so buchhaltung papierkram zu
machen und die wohnungen einzurichten
aufzuräumen und die gerade nun
eingezogen würde ich gerade mein studio
einrichten
ich hab melanie so stolz auf mich warten
bei unserem instagram account mache das
ist ein instagram post zu diesem blog
der wiederum zuletzt im video ist social
media section das bedeutet wenn ihr euch
dafür interessiert wie man unfalls
spannendes leben sonst so aussieht dann
folgt uns auf instagram schön schlau mit
wohlgemerkt und da tobe ich mich ab und
an ein wenig aus in den stories
zumindest einen spannenden tag
heute bin ich dabei bin ich live
gesungen oder letztlich den konnte
bestimmt schon zum 10
ich könnt ihr was essen oder was kann
ich denn dann wird wieder ein vermehrt
man erstmal wie oft mal am tag an essen
denkt ich kann nichts anderes
ich wurde gerade glücklich sein ich kann
ja nichts anderes essen wirklich hunger
wenn es irgendwie nicht geht dann in
echtzeit ab ich muss seiner
dokumentieren auch so falls ihr euch
fragt ob ich mich einfach nicht vom
fleck bewegen
so ähnlich ist und tatsächlich ich spare
mir meine energie aus neulich hat den
kaffee gemacht ich glaube dass dumme
idee aber ich habe so los war
das erinnert mich doch da ein bisschen
anheizen und der kaffee halten
[Musik]
es ist ganz schlimm es ist viertel nach
fünf und mein mann macht ich gerade
kleinen krieg
die noch vom früheren nicht frische
junge ziegen ein schon damit an dass die
pfanne so schön geknistert hat 36
stunden
im moment fühle ich mich so als könnte
ich das heute nicht durchhalten
und je nachdem ich jetzt 15 minuten die
tag rum saß machen konnte es ist jetzt
ein knäckebrot kurzes update ich bin hat
sich die schlafen gegangen nach dem
krieg im brot domain grad eigentlich
wieder gut mein mann markiert er der
beste ist heute mit mir mit damit sich
das besser durch halte und auch
solidarität
es ist immer ein wechsel zwischen es
völlig geräumt ist jetzt überhaupt mache
und so ein gefühl von es geht mir
eigentlich ganz gut erstaunlich
jedenfalls im moment habe ich jetzt ein
unglaubliches leid ich habe das gefühl
ich könnte gar nichts mehr machen
deswegen hätte ich die entscheidung
schon gegessen anderthalb scheiben käse
möglicher gewieft und voraus werden das
zu hause nachmachen weil es einfach
keinen spaß machen ich bin für einen
kleinen powernap halten ich saß die
letzte stunde 1 nur auf dem stuhl im
wohnzimmer und verkauft und körperlich
anstrengt ich hoffe die ganze werbung wo
leckeres essen angetrieben wie du nicht
verspüre keine tief vergraben ich fühl
mich super wachleute ich weiß nicht ob
da gibt's das ist aber meine stimmung
tag 3 der tag startet heute definitiv
viel besser als gestern das liegt
natürlich auch daran wie weit das wird
endlich wieder zu essen bekommen seit
gestern abend 11 uhr geht es mir relativ
gut
man bringt
ja wenn ihr im mai getroffen haben
[Musik]
studien gegenüber 20 minuten
ich muss mir super aber körperlich habe
einfach keine energie
ich glaube ich muss mich tatsächlich
noch mal hinlegen ein kleines schläfchen
machen fasste lieber nicht wie die nicht
die gelegenheit zur abwehr sehr viel zu
schlafen
2 uhr ich hab sehr unruhig geschlafen
aber noch fünf stunden noch fünf stunden
wir haben nicht nur am tag 3 das heißt
ich habe fast geschafft drei tage fasten
kein fazit ist
ich bin erstaunt ist das doch so gut
ging dafür dass sie sonst immer dreimal
am tag essen und auch von zwischen
transnet bin ich ziemlich erstaunt wie
gut man tatsächlich noch leben kann wenn
man so gut wie nichts ist von hand
zwischen sind tatsächlich fahren wollen
über keinen hunger mehr verspürt man
kann werbung von schokokuchen im
fernsehen schauen lässt einfältigkeit
eine stunde später wie man in der küche
einfach nur den kochtopf bestehen und
denkt an essen wird verrückt typische
vorstellen das ganz gut wäre zum
beispiel einmal im jahr eine fastenkur
zu machen also nicht so einfach
irgendwie im alltag
mit programmen mit experten wichtig ist
glaube ich dass man sich die zeichen
dass eine art urlaub oder wirklich uhr
an wieder nicht einfach den dokumenten
einfach mal nicht man nimmt sondern
markiert generell ein bisschen für ihren
stoffwechsel ab das liegt wahrscheinlich
daran dass ein marathon läuft da war
tatsächlich heute morgen gelaufen weil
er nicht schlafen konnte das hätte ich
nicht hinbekommen ich ganz klar fest
ende ist dass ich körperlich einfach wer
wenig energie aber war heute ein
bisschen trauten unterlegten bieten
einkaufen da fand ich unglaublich
anstrengend und ich freue mich einfach
zu sehr auf das essen nach einer stunde
einschläge zu hören
[Musik]